- Well welcome to the Khan
Academy Daily Homeroom.
This is a way that we're
trying to stay in touch
and help support parents,
teachers, and students
as we go through this
school closure situation.
Many of y'all know, at Khan Academy,
we're not for profit with
a mission of providing
a free world class education
for anyone, anywhere
and we could have never
predicted the scenario
we're now in, this very
suboptimal situation.
But over the last 10 years
or so we've been building
resources that now can
really help you as a student,
a parent, or a teacher bridge, make sure
that everyone can keep
learning through this crisis.
I do wanna remind folks
that we are not for profit,
we are funded by philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position
to do so, please think about
donating to Khan Academy,
you can see some links
on the screen right over here.
I do want do, give a
special shout out to several
help us fund our gap.
We were running at a deficit even before
this crisis started, and now our usage
is about 250% of normal
and so you can imagine
our budget situation has gotten
even a little bit more serious.
So special thanks to Bank of America,
which is really the first to step up,
that first weekend when
the school closures
were happening, we were
seeing that traffic spike,
followed closely by AT&T,
Google.org and Novartis.
So whether you're an individual or someone
who represents a corporation,
we still need help,
we're still running at a
deficit, and we have a lot
of ideas of what we would like to do
to support more folks through this crisis.
But we are somewhat gated
by resources at the moment.
Now, the fun of this
session is it's really,
we wanna make it as
interactive as possible.
So whatever social media
you're watching this on,
whether it's Facebook or
YouTube or someplace else,
that we're always adding new things to it,
feel free, ask questions
on the discussion board.
And this is a forum, very
informal, literally ask anything.
I would like to be surprised.
No question will offend us and it's fun
to discuss not just how Khan
Academy resources might be used
or how we might navigate this crisis
or implications in
education, these are all
very interesting topics,
but I'm also happy to answer
questions about other things
that are interesting to you
or maybe sometimes we
wanna talk about things
other than COVID right
now, but we can obviously
talk about that as well.
And I have team members
on Khan Academy, Dan,
who will join us and there's
Dan right over there,
who will help, myself and Dan,
and some of our team members
are gonna be looking at the
comments as they come in.
And so we will answer any
questions that you might have.
And so if I look, and we
have a few announcements
that we've been making over
the last couple of days.
One of them is we've
released these schedules
about three, four weeks
ago, that first weekend
when the closures were
happening and we get
a lot of feedback from
parents, students, and teachers
that they would want even
more detailed resources,
so above and beyond the
live stream, the schedules,
the webinars we're running,
we released learning plans
for students to keep them
learning through the summer.
Not just through the
end of the school year,
but also leveraging summer
for a time of learning.
And so these are, if you
to our main, I guess,
COVID Response Center, you can
see the URLs on the screen,
you will see these new learning plans.
And depending on whether your
third grade, fourth grade,
fifth grade, all the
way up through algebra
and algebra two and geometry,
a week by week goals
for getting mastery on Khan Academy.
So highly encourage
folks to check that out
and keep learning over break.
And so let's see, we have,
we're starting to get
some questions, one from
YouTube, Anouj Baguan says,
"Hey Sal, what motivates you
to always push the limits?"
Well, I don't know if I'm
always pushing the limits,
but I think the things that
Khan Academy is working on
and our mission and what we aspire to do,
there's urgency to it.
You have, even before this COVID crisis,
you have hundreds of millions
of students around the world,
arguably billions, who
have access to some form
of schooling but could use more support.
So you have millions of
teachers around the world
who know that they wanna
support their students
in better ways, but it's
difficult if you're a teacher
in a classroom of 30
students and every student
has their own different learning needs,
is learning at a different pace.
They need tools to be
able to support them.
And all of these things
of how do you allow
more people to have access
to world class resources,
how do you create better
tools for teachers,
how do you connect that
to opportunity that exists
in the real world and higher
education or internships
or jobs, those are always important
and they've just now
become a lot more important
because of this COVID crisis.
So I speak for myself and I
speak for a lot of the team
members and a lot of the
folks supporting Khan Academy,
there's an urgency here.
I always think about for
every Albert Einstein
we know about or every
Marie Curie we know about,
how many others we're never
able to fulfill their potential.
And that's a shame even
on individual level
that they could have
maybe done so much more
and it's also a shame for
humanity because that person
could have found the cure for
a disease or could have found
a way to solve a major
issue in our society.
And I suspect that for every
Albert or Alberta Einstein
we discover, historically
there's probably been
50 or 100 that we don't
discover, that never got
the educational opportunities,
never got to tap
into their potential.
And so Khan Academy can
be part of the solution
to increase by an order of
magnitude, by a factor of 10
the number that we can discover.
And not just those very
special circumstances
like an Albert Einstein,
but the whole distribution.
So more people can
participate in the economy.
We're definitely getting
into a world with automation
that you need higher level
skills in order to participate.
We know what's happening with
robotics, with computing,
that's going to be able
to do a lot of the skills
that labor has historically done.
So as we get more productive,
we have two choices.
We either have to get all
of humanity to be able
to participate in the knowledge economy,
and I hope Khan Academy
can play a role there,
or we're going to have tougher times.
And obviously what's
going on economically now
makes that even clearer.
So let's see, other
questions that I'm getting,
and I'm having my regular
mouse is a little strange
right now so please bear
with me a little bit.
So there is Facebook, Neon Khan asks,
"Sal, can you speak
Bengali for me, please."
Any of my Bengali family
members will cringe
if I start to speak Bengali.
(speaking foreign language).
Our accent (speaking foreign language).
So for those of you who
do not know Bengali,
I just said I can speak Bengali,
I can get by, but my accent is really bad.
But I try.
I'm sorry, I think I
made about 400 million
Bengali speakers around the world cringe.
But that's, I guess, you know.
Neon asked for that.
All right, so from YouTube,
Katherine Pierce asks,
"What's coming to Khan Academy next?"
So, there's a lot of things
going on at Khan Academy,
some of which we have talked
about and some of which
we're trying to accelerate
because of this COVID crisis.
English and language arts,
many of y'all are familiar,
we just launched what's
known as a beta version.
In software world beta is
like, it's not even quite
a first version, it's
a version that you put
out there to start to
learn about how it's used,
what's good about it, what's not.
We know it's not a perfect version.
A lot of the modalities on
Khan Academy were first made
for the math and sciences
and so you can imagine
when we try to put reading comprehension
into that same modality sometimes
it's a little bit awkward.
Ideally in reading comprehension,
it's not just a passage
and a question and then another
passage and the question,
you want a passage and
then four or five questions
like we do in our SAT practice.
So we're working on, hopefully
over the next many months,
improving things like that.
We are continuing to
partner with districts
and we might be accelerating
that over the course
of this crisis because
more and more districts
are thinking about how do
they keep students learning
in times of school closures,
and that's on top of the need
that districts have always recognized.
That they administer standardized tests,
they see that students,
some students are ready
for grade level work, some
students have a lot of gaps
in their knowledge, some
students are ready to move ahead.
But they've historically not had
a good way of differentiating.
And tools like Khan Academy
can be helpful there.
So we're working with
districts to provide things
like district dashboards
and rostering with them.
We hope to continue to, you'll be seeing
our chemistry content
is getting significantly
flushed out, we are constantly improving
our math content, we are hoping
to add even more subjects.
So we're talking to philanthropists about
wouldn't it be great if we
could fund middle school science
and things like that.
And so that's, if you're a philanthropist,
please contact us if you're interested
in funding things like that.
Longer term, we're
thinking about simple ways
to help place and diagnose
folks on Khan Academy.
So right now we have
a lot of the resources
that you can start as early as
pre-k with Khan Academy Kids.
You can see Cody right behind
me gazing over my shoulder.
But we have most of the content from pre-k
all the way through elementary,
middle, and high school.
For sure in math and
science, but increasingly
in the humanities and
English and language arts.
But, because there's so much
content, sometimes folks
are like, "Where do I start, what do I do
"if maybe I'm in a certain
grade but I have gaps,
"or maybe I'm in a certain
grade, I'm ready to move ahead,
"or I already know some of the material."
And we've been putting out
material during this crisis
about how to use our mastery mechanics.
If you think you already
know some of sixth grade,
go take the course challenge
and when you start seeing
diminishing returns there,
go take the unit test,
et cetera et cetera.
But we wanna make it
more, we wanna put that
in the experience better,
make it a little bit easier
for people to understand where they can go
and what types of courses
maybe we can curate
for certain, for those different cases.
So the simple answer is we
just add a lot of content,
a lot more content, we wanna
make it a lot easier to use,
find what you need to work
on, a lot more engaging.
We have some, I hope we can
get this for back to school,
but we definitely have some
team members who are thinking
about how to make the navigation
on the site a lot easier.
So we definitely have our
work cut out a lot there
'cause we're literally
trying to cover 13 years
of all of the core academic subjects
and build tools for teachers
and support classrooms.
Simultaneously, we have
59 translation projects
around the world.
So we are also thinking
about how we can support
other geographies, in
particular, places like Brazil
and India where we
actually have, and Peru,
where we actually have team members there
who are helping drive
Khan Academy's mission
in those geographies.
I'm sure I'm missing things,
but that's some of what
Khan Academy has going forward.
- Hi Sal, Adnan Abest
Kensuala from YouTube
asks, "Sal, what's one
thing you wanna master
"while being at home?"
- One thing I wanna master
while being at home.
I think I'm trying to master
balancing life and work.
I don't know if that's,
you wanted a middle level
answer like that, but you can imagine
now with school closures,
my kids are home.
And I've said this at other live streams,
I think all of us who are,
especially in some degree
my job at Khan Academy has gotten busier,
there's more to do to
the previous question.
I feel more urgency
than ever to try to get
some of this stuff done that
we've been talking about
for a very long time.
But if your five-year-old is screaming
or wants your attention,
it's a tough tension.
And I don't feel sorry
for myself 'cause I know
there's millions of
parents around the world
that are going through at
least what I'm going through,
probably far worse.
I have a lot of supports at home, my wife,
my mother-in-law, we've all been trying
to tag team this, and
frankly they've been,
I've been able to lean on them even more
even though my wife has
a full time job as well.
But because of all the Khan
Academy thing picking up.
So I think mastering
that balance is something
that a lot of parents are
struggling with right now.
And one thing that's
clicked in my head recently
is, you know, as much urgency
as I feel towards my job
and as much urgency as
I feel towards work,
those are moments you
don't wanna let go of.
When your eight-year-old,
when she asks for help
or she wants to show
something that she made
or she has a question for
you, because that time,
their childhood, goes by very fast.
So I'm trying to just make
sure that I can enjoy that
and give them the time they
need while also making sure
that Khan Academy is able
to continue to support
many, many, many people right now.
That's, yeah, I think
that's the biggest thing.
I've had a lifelong quest to,
I guess you'd call it a fitness quest.
It's a lot of things on a
diet and nutritional side
that I've been trying to master,
but sometimes I fall off the wagon.
So from YouTube, Mac Par asks,
"Did you expect Khan Academy
to be this successful?"
Mac, yes and no.
When I was a kid, and maybe
not even so much a kid,
even when I was in my 20s and Khan Academy
was a, I was tutoring my cousins,
there was definitely a part
of me, and it's still there,
that I daydream a lot and
I definitely would have
these moments where I'm like,
"Hey, this thing that
I'm tutoring my cousins
"and if I make tools for
them, maybe it scales
"and if it's useful for
them, maybe it could be
"useful for millions or
billions of people one day.
"And wouldn't it be cool if
one day there was a new type
"of institution where anyone on the planet
"had access to learning."
And I've cited being inspired by books
like Isaac Asimov's "Foundations" series
where in that book a galactic civilization
and someone creates a
foundation at the edge
of the empire to shorten
a thousands of year
galactic dark ages.
And I remember always
being inspired by saying,
yeah, knowledge is the thing
that can most support society
and keep us from, I guess,
falling apart and devolving,
so to speak.
And so I've always thought those kind of,
I guess you could say, grand thoughts,
but then usually after
I let myself go on one
of those visions for five or 10 minutes,
I'd be like, "Sal, be realistic.
"Just put one foot in front of the other,
"just do the next right
thing," to quote "Frozen II"
and move from there.
And so I would kind of then
just get very, very practical.
I could have never imagined
that when I was tutoring
my cousins, 13, 14
years ago or when I quit
my day job about 10 or 11 years ago
that I would have truly
evolved as fast as it has.
But I always did keep
that somewhat delusional
thing in the back of my mind of well maybe
this could be like a Smithsonian
or a great university
or even operate at a
scale 100 or 1000 times
larger than that.
And now that Khan Academy
is of a larger scale
and with this COVID crisis,
it is playing a, I guess
you could say, an institutional role here
for millions of folks,
tens of millions of folks
around the world, I'm
a little less bashful
speaking openly about these aspirations
of it becoming a
multi-generational institution
that can empower billions
of folks over time.
So I still try to balance, and I think
that's the interesting thing about life,
you're always trying to
balance putting one leg
in front of the other and
not getting too far ahead
of yourself and staying humble, frankly,
with having big goals, big
visions, and not being afraid
to use a baseball analogy,
swing for the fences.
And so that's always been
my hope for Khan Academy.
But you know, I gotta say, even today,
as far as Khan Academy
has gone, I'm always,
my stress level can
sometimes be pretty high
'cause I'm like, we can't blow it now.
We have to go so much further
to empower so many more.
Dan, more questions.
- Yeah, so from YouTube,
Ashtush Tawari asks,
"Hi Sal, many people are trying
to start a YouTube channel
"and make tutorials just like you,
"especially during this
crisis, but not everybody
"is Salman Khan.
"What advice would you give for someone?"
Actually, this question, Sal, we also get
from a lot of teachers
who are having to do
remote teaching right now and
they would love your advice
in terms of just how to present online.
- You know, my number one
advice, a lot of times
folks end up focusing on the optics
and does it look professional versus
I would say, the authenticity
and the human element of it.
And my number one advice
to anyone making content,
whether they're doing it kind
of in a Khan Academy style
with a pen tablet or they're
just doing a video like this
is be yourself, you laugh at yourself,
don't be afraid to make mistakes,
be as authentic as possible.
Human beings can know when
someone else is not themselves,
when they're not being authentic,
when they're reading a script.
And you might be reading a
script for a very good reason,
you wanna get all your language precise
et cetera, et cetera, but I
think there's a nice balance.
You wanna have the right
vocabulary, you wanna get
your language right, but
there's something powerful
about the learner seeing
that you are working
through them, you're truly
thinking through it with them.
I think another point
of advice is to view,
I've heard from some teachers it's hard
to teach to the screen
'cause you might be used
to other folks in the room.
And this is where maybe my
day dreaming imagination
has been an asset.
I imagine when I make content,
I imagine that I'm talking
to my cousins or my
cousins at a certain age
or my family members.
I think it creates a connection
and I think even though
we are using technology
and we're going to be,
you know, I'm making the
content now and it might be used
by thousands of people at another time,
they'll feel that connection in it.
Another thing I would say
is try to really focus
on the connections and concepts.
Too many times, not just in math,
but pretty much in every
subject, concepts are taught
in isolation and even a little comment,
a little connection to like, well yeah,
this is why plastics are stretchy,
after just did a video
on amorphous solids.
So that's why it's front of mind for me.
Or that's why, I mean,
actually one of the fun things
that actually I didn't include in my video
is why eggs become solid
when you heat it up
and that's because the proteins denature
and what would be these bound proteins,
these globular proteins they become these
kind of stringy things
and get all entangled
with each other and so
that's why the egg white
gets kind of, kind of
becomes an amorphous solid,
so to speak.
But yeah, if you can connect
things to the real world,
if you can connect things
to what people knew before.
In Khan Academy videos
you'll often hear me say,
"Hey, this might look
like another concept,
"but it really is just an extension
"of completing the square."
The quadratic formula is
just completing the square
for any quadratic or the
quotient rule in calculus
really is just the product
and the chain rules combined.
So I think the more that
you can connect things
to what learners already
know, and there's a lot
of learning science behind that as well.
That people like to be grounded
in what they already know.
And most of knowledge is that way,
it is connected to other things.
So that's' my best advice.
And have fun doing it.
If you don't have fun making the content,
the person listening to the content
is not going to have fun.
And if you're not
passionate about the content
and excited about it,
it's going to be hard
for the other person
to be excited about it.
So one thing I tell myself
and everyone at Khan Academy
who makes content is, and not
just video content actually,
even exercises and things like articles,
if you're not excited
about it, if you don't feel
the energy, if you don't see the beauty
in the concept, it's going to be very hard
for student to feel that same thing
and we want them to feel that.
And the reality is
pretty much every concept
has a beauty to it, has
an intuitiveness to it,
has a connection to other
things and has connection
to the real world.
So let's see, there's a
question, an interesting one
from Angel Chobra from YouTube.
"Are there any positives that resulted,
"or maybe might result from
the coronavirus epidemic?"
Well, as you can imagine as
we're in the midst of it,
it's hard to see sometimes
the silver lining.
If I were to, and it's easy
to point to a lot of things
that are stressful or are not
so great about the crisis,
if I were to say some of the positives
or the silver linings, you
know, I talked a little earlier
about spending time with family.
I think a lot of us, if we're lucky enough
to be with our families
right now, this is time
that it's in every day
life when we're on our,
doing the daily grind, so to speak,
it's easy to take family for granted,
it's easy to take friends for granted.
And now we, whether it's in person,
I'm able to spend more time with my kids,
with my wife, this is
time we'll never forget
and we'll never get back.
So I think there's
something powerful there.
I think this crisis,
there's something about it
that makes us want to reach
out to our family members
and be more connected with them.
You know, I've talked on this live stream
about my mom, she's alone,
lives alone in New Orleans
right now which is having
a very high per capita
incidence of COVID and my
mom, as you can imagine,
is in that high risk group.
And so just my worry
for her physical health,
and frankly her mental
health, 'cause she's living
by herself now, I've told myself, "Sal,
"you can't just say hey,
I need to finish this task
"at work and I'll call my mom tomorrow,"
you've gotta call your mom every day
and have a conversation with her.
And it's been great, I've been doing it
because of the crisis,
but I've kind of realized
that I should be doing this all the time.
That it shouldn't' just
be during the crisis.
And we're having good conversations
even though we're 2,000 miles apart.
Better conversations,
frankly, then when I call
every three days or we
only chat once a week.
So I think that's been important.
I've been connecting
with friends and family
that I haven't talked
to for five, 10 years
on Zoom and Google Hangouts.
So those are positives.
I think on the education side,
obviously school closures
are very suboptimal, but I'm hoping
that some of the tools
that we might accelerate,
Khan Academy and others
might accelerate and build
to respond to the crisis,
those will exist after
so that's a silver lining.
I'm hoping that some of the
habits, some of the patterns
that students and teachers
and parents are forming
during the crisis will
have lasting benefit.
If you, as a student, are learning hey,
I can structure my day,
I can keep learning,
I can do that during the summers,
I can do that when I'm an adult,
even after I've graduated
from high school or college,
those are super useful skills.
Arguably the most important
skills that can last you
an entire lifetime.
We were just talking about
teachers and other folks
making lessons online
to help their students,
that's great, that's going
to have lasting implications
beyond the crisis.
Now that folks realize how
important online access
at home is, we're seeing a
lot of telecom companies,
philanthropists, Ray and Barbara Dalio,
two philanthropists we know
who've been long time supporters
of Khan Academy, they've
just distributed 60,000
laptops in Connecticut to low
income high school students.
We're seeing school
districts, like Las Vegas,
Clark County, we had Dr. Jara on last week
talking about how they
are distributing laptops
and working with local cable companies
to get wifi access or get online access.
These are things that I
hope can lay groundwork
that's permanent so that even
once we're past this crisis
people will have that
access, which is empowering
on so many levels.
I think just the cracks that
we're seeing in our society,
large numbers of people, due
to no fault of their own,
aren't able to work now
because of they were working
at a restaurant or a travel
agency or an airline,
all of these things that even once we get
through the worst of the
stay in place orders,
it's unlikely that those industries
are going to come back fully.
We talked about that last
week with Bill Gates.
I think that's making all of us recognize
and governments recognize that hey,
yeah, we probably do need
supports for these folks
because for no fault of their own,
in order to protect the public
safety, they're suffering
and they need some way
to support their family.
So regardless of where you
are on the political spectrum,
I think it's making us
all realize that hey,
there's some supports that folks need.
So I think all of these types of things
as we go through the
crisis will hopefully have
some positive lasting implications.
We could think of more,
feel free to add any
that you could think of
on the message boards.
We're happy to take a look at it.
So from Facebook, Samara Abidrabo says,
"For college students, do
you think that we should move
"to more critical thinking tests
"that are open book since
the works have changed
"with so much access to information."
Samara, I think yes and no.
I think there's sometimes
a view, you'll hear this,
and you'll actually hear this
commonly in education circles,
oh people can Google everything now,
why should people know, why
should people have facts
or content knowledge that
they can Google that stuff
and then they can just
work on the projects,
or the applied, or the
critical thinking parts of it.
Learning science actually tells us,
I'm actually reading a book right now
about this kind of a
survey of learning science,
something that we take very
seriously at Khan Academy,
and the reality is is
that factual knowledge,
that content knowledge,
whether it's at a kind of
a factual level or at a conceptual level,
is super valuable for forming
that critical thinking.
And so I think there's always
going to be a very important
place for having that core knowledge
and it will allow you to
build more connections.
And if you have some
of that core knowledge,
you don't have to apply as
much of your cognitive load
when you have to do more complex
tasks through those things.
One way to think about it is
you're playing basketball,
or let's say you're learning a new sport.
Let's say you've never
played basketball before,
you can focus on the rules of the game
and maybe movements that are
new to you, like dribbling,
but you don't have to think
about things like walking
or jumping, those are things
you know how to do already
because they're so automatic.
And there's analogs in
the learning world there.
In math, something like your
core multiplication tables.
It's of course, important to understand
what multiplication really is
or how it can be represented,
but if when you're doing
algebra you have to sit
and think, wait, is nine times six,
is it 54 or is it 56,
that's going to make it
very hard for you to
engage in the algebra.
Or if you are trying to think critically
about economic, we talk
the situation right now,
if you're trying to think about well,
what could be the economic implications
of this COVID crisis, if you don't already
in the back of your mind
have context of saying
okay, well we've gone through
this like this before,
you had the Great Depression
which was in the 1930s,
and then okay, what was the
historical context there,
how did we get out of it?
Well, there was World War
II, there was the Great Deal,
sorry, the New Deal, and you could say,
well how much did each of
those things contribute.
If you don't have some of
that knowledge base there,
it's very hard to think
critically about new situations.
So I'm a big proponent and
a lot of what we try to do
with Khan Academy is
give you that practice,
not just at the most basic level of facts,
but at the conceptual level
and at that understanding,
comprehending level so
that you build that fluency
so you can go higher and higher up that,
you know, it's often known as
Bloom's Cognitive Taxonomy,
Bloom's Cognitive Taxonomy of Skills
so you can go higher and higher on that.
So I don't think it's an either or,
I think it's actually a value to having
some of that core knowledge.
So there's a question from
Patty Prentice on Facebook.
"I am a college student, will the pandemic
"affect availability of
classes offered in the future?
"I heard that colleges
and universities will have
"fewer students because of the pandemic."
Patty, it's a fascinating question.
I don't think, I definitely
am not an expert here
and I have been talking to
some university administrators
and people who are
familiar, and I don't think
anyone really knows how
all of this will settle.
As you could imagine, we hope
that we're through the worst
of the stay in place
orders and school closures
as we go back to school,
and hopefully the colleges
and universities like K
through 12 will be able
to open back up, but you could imagine
that if the virus goes,
starts going exponential again
and starts picking back up,
it might have to be closed down again.
So it is going to be a
hard time for universities.
And there is a situation
where a lot of students
are saying, hey well, the
university's going virtual,
maybe I can just stay in virtual.
So some of that might
happen and there are things
like virtual universities and
MOOCs and things like that.
You know, personally,
I found a lot of value
in the physical experience of university,
that's where I met my
wife, that's where I met
some of my best friends
that I talked about
that I connect with on a regular basis.
Some of whom even start
Khan Academy and helped
other things, so I think
college is really powerful
from a social connection
and building yourself
in many dimension point of view.
But I think this crisis
does make us ask questions
of like well, what
aspects are nice to have,
what aspects are must haves,
and there's a resourcing question.
College is increasingly expensive
and so are there pathways
that could be more
flexible, that can focus
on the must haves, and
that could leave students
with a lot less debt.
When we say we want,
we're a not for profit
with a free world class
education for anyone, anywhere,
that's because we don't
think someone's education
should hold back their ability
to be empowered in the world,
but we know far too many
people, and I know people
even in my own family who
the debt they've incurred
has been somewhat debilitating, actually,
for their ability to
participate in society
because of college.
So we'll see how all of this plays out.
Well anyway, these were great questions,
we will continue this.
We're here every day at 12 p.m. Pacific,
three p.m. Eastern in the U.S..
So whatever time zone you all
are in you can figure it out,
it's a place for us to
just stay connected,
answer questions about
education, the economy,
viruses, we have exciting slate of guests.
We're probably gonna have
two or three guests a week
that are interesting and have expertise
in different areas.
And I'll just remind everyone, stay safe,
stay healthy, and if you're
in a position to do so,
please think about
donating to Khan Academy,
we need the help, especially if we're able
to support more folks through this crisis.
Thank you.